the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I'm very interested in teaching in ways
that really help you learn and one of
the most difficult things to learn is
when you have to unlearn something you
believe so if you have learned a concept
wrong in your previous education and
learnings your mind is really reluctant
to let go of it okay and one of the
aibum a wife is a middle school science
teacher she also has PhD in biology but
she's really studies to understand kids
and how they learn and MIT students
aren't much different from sixth graders
tell you the truth when it comes to
learning none of us are the but they're
just a little more transparent the what
you can do to help a person unlearn
something they've learned wrong the best
time is when you run into something
called a discrepant event so and you
think you know the answer and I'm asking
you these questions you're wrong really
try to figure out what it is you believe
that led you to that and see if you can
undo that in getting to the answer so
some of these concept to talk about them
further I think they're great for
discussions in your recitation section
look at professor Gossard here so bring
you know talk about these things and
really try to get to the bottom of why
you perhaps had a concept it wasn't
quite wasn't quite up to what you needed
okay we're going to move on okay
now we're going to get on to talking
about velocities in rotating frames and
bio velocities that also mean
derivatives of vectors in rotating
frames
just to give you a quick reminder of
where we started this conversation this
is concept if you have three points a B
and O and the sixth frame this is our a
with respect to O B with respect to ay B
with respect to O all vectors and we're
interested in computing the velocities
of say point B so we were talking about
the derivative with respect to time of
this vector we can make it up as the sum
of the derivatives with respect to time
of these other two vectors but now
there's a really important point when
you take in time derivatives you have to
be explicit about what it's with respect
to what frame of reference you're
talking about in this case we're talking
about the frame of reference with we
want to know the velocity with respect
to this reference frame so both of these
derivatives have to be taken with
respect to that frame well this one's
this one's easy
it just this is purely translational it
has nothing to do with rotations or blur
what we're going to think in terms of
having an object out here so maybe a
rigid body to which we've attached a
rotating frame at a and I'll call this
the rotating reference frame a x-prime
y-prime it might be rotating but this
point is just a point of which we
described the translation of the body so
this one's pretty easy listen is just
the velocity of a with respect to O but
this is where the this one has
complications and I'm going to do it
first the answer to this just
intuitively appeal to your intuition
about why this should be
so this is my my merry-go-round and I've
got I've set up my little coordinate
system this is my a x-prime y-prime
coordinate system I've stuck my dog here
on the x-axis and if he's running some
direction he has a velocity with respect
to this reference frame if you're if
you're here at a watch at him you'll see
him moving and it will have nothing to
do with the rotation you will just see
the dog moving and if this is rotating
and you're sitting there rotating with
it watching the dog there's the motion
of the dog change you just see it just
the same way right okay so there's one
part of the motion of the of the dog
that's with respect to this frame that
has nothing to do with rotation okay so
now let's say in and outside from an
outside point of view if we measure the
velocity of the dog with respect to
point a that's the one you can see and
to observer outside says what's the
velocity of dog with respect to a will
the answer differ if there's rotation
okay now so we're going to find out is
that there's actually two contributions
so the dog running with respect to this
merry-go-round is one contribution to
the velocity there's another
contribution that comes from the fact
you're sitting out there watching and
you say definitely the dog moves when
the thing rotates right okay and if we
only do that the only rotation will do a
case where there's no the dogs not
running just sitting still what's the
velocity of the dog with respect to
point a due to the rotation I mean
you've done lots of problems like this
this is just pure rotation problem you
know the angular rate theta dot or Omega
what's the velocity of point B if point
a is fixed and this thing rotates
our Omega you know you all know that
okay and it will just let's and then
we'll call the velocity of the dog
relative to point a due to the fact that
he's moving in this frame will call that
velocity to the dog from the point of
view of in the frame is a different
quantity
they're both vectors and you can add
them together so in fact the answer is
going to right give you the answer to
this problem the answer to this is the
velocity of a with respect to O plus the
derivative of R b/a with respect to time
as seen from within the a X Y Z prime
frame plus a term here due to rotation
and we know that the magnitude of this
answer is some R Omega we know it looks
like R Omega okay so interpret this as
meaning the derivative of this vector
this thing as if you were in the frame
and that counts for the dog running this
is just the dog running and I like to
think mathematically I actually sort of
find it easier to say what this piece
means is this is the velocity of the dog
with respect to a with omega equal to
zero it's the same thing this is what
you see if there's no rotation that
piece and this is a piece with rotation
but I want you to think figure some
think something through here
I'm on I'm still learning how to do this
okay so I little reference frames like
this I'm going to rotate it in this
direction which given XYZ ought to be in
that direction so the rotation rate if
it's going like this I'm going to give
it a constant value is that the vector
Omega is some Omega in the K hat
direction right and I have on this body
a here's my here's my wheel and here's B
and here's a and this is my little
x-axis my X prime axis and it has
associated with it and a lowercase I hat
unit vector and off in this direction
then would be the Y prime with a J hat
unit vector okay so what's the vector RB
a how would you write it in vector
notation in components here so this is
our BA I'm here to hit from here to here
and what's its direction
I have and is it positive or negative
so some mag this is the vector it's some
magnitude RBA in the positive I hat
direction the arrow goes when you say
RBA this is B with respect to a the
arrow goes at B okay so this it's
positive RBA I hat and what is the
velocity that we've discovered up here
the velocity of B with respect to a as
measured inside of a XYZ that's this
piece here in vector terms
what's the blah so this magnet and we
figured out what his velocity was it's
some R Omega the ars RBA
the amplitude magnitude of the length of
that are clearly got to be this length
right here and the Omega is given so
what direction you know that the
magnitudes are Omega what's the
direction J hat okay so what we're
saying is the velocity of B with respect
to a as seen from inside this a-frame is
RBA Omega with respect to O in the J hat
direction now so we've got this has a K
associated with it that is an eye
associated with it this has a J
associated with it so it's a product R
Omega what kind of product is it what
you know about vectors what does it have
to be is it a dot product between Omega
and R is it a cross product I hear
somebody say cross product but what's
the order so I want you to figure out
just deduce what the vector notation is
that gets you the right velocity right
the correct velocity correct magnitude
and correct direction so the answer is
positive
our Omega J Omega Omega cross R so I
hear one person Omega with respect to O
cross R b/a and these are not both
vectors anybody else so we just think
about unit vector rationals check it
this is K hat direction this was I hat
direction and K cross I is positive J so
that works so in general this is in fact
the engine the correct answer in general
is that this this term here is Omega
with respect to O cross RBA you're going
to see you're going to use that a lot so
to summarize then the
well that's coming down the velocity of
this dog in a stationary frame where a
is stationary for a moment is entirely
due to the rotation and it's a mega
cross RBA and now if the dog starts to
run with respect to this reference frame
he has some velocity which is the other
piece is lhasa T of B with respect to a
at seen from a or as you would compute e
just set momentarily Omega equal to zero
and finally then the total formula for
velocity so the velocity of B with
respect to O some point on a rotating
reference frame is the velocity of the
frame plus I won't write it as a
derivative now plus the velocity of the
point but as seen from the point of view
of somebody in the frame plus Omega with
respect to O across R b/a
so this is an important formula you can
use a lot a couple settle points in here
this one this thing from as seen from
inside the frame it's also the parse
it's the partial derivative of RBA with
respect to T when Omega with respect to
O equals zero that's that's another way
to say this plan this term is another
subtlety I was careful to write with
respect to O yes
yes so this was when we were working
with just the velocity due to the wrote
due to the mo the motion of the dog due
to rotation plus actually this is
rotation when I say yes you know I can't
remember how I got to this point but I
think I was making a couple of points
and ran them together so this is the
correct this is don't don't focus on
this this is the summary this thing is
now rotating and translating and the
dogs running and I want you to be able
to write down the total velocity of the
point B as seen from a fixed reference
frame fixed on the ground this is with
respect to O it has three terms the
velocity of a the velocity of the dog
relative to the body it's on here and
finally the compound of the velocity
contribution velocity that's you see
that's due to the rotation now this
turns out to be a really powerful
formula it's a generalization it's a
spent special case of a very general
formula let me catch up in my notes here
because the following statement is true
so any the time derivative
time derivative of any vector that's
defined in a rotating frame is given by
we'll call it the vector just some
vector a it might be for example angular
momentum in fact we'll use this formula
lot when talking about angular momentum
the time derivative of this vector a
whatever it represents position velocity
angular momentum as seen from a
reference frame XY o XYZ reference frame
o is made up of the derivative of a from
inside the frame plus
so it says this it's this the same thing
this was a derivative of RBA has two
pieces the piece that came from the dog
running and the peace that comes from
rotation any vector this piece is true
it's the derivative of the vector inside
the frame that is it which it's defined
plus Omega with respect to the reference
frame you want the derivative in cross a
very powerful formula
so there's a you know this now is
covered in a couple of different places
in the readings and in the handout
that's posted called kinematics so you
should read by now the portion of the
kinematics thing at least on velocities
the second half of that kinematics
handout is about acceleration so we're
going to use this formula to go from
velocity to acceleration I saw a couple
hands up yes okay so this is a
merry-go-round on a train and you're
looking down on it and the Train can
move and we fix to the ground not moving
a reference frame we call oh and I want
to know in this case the velocity of the
dog running around on this
merry-go-round with respect to oh it's
the sum of three vector contributions
the velocity of the Train the velocity
of the dog with respect to the
merry-go-round this is velocity of the
Train this is with respect to the
merry-go-round and this is the velocity
that you see out there you see you're
sitting in oh you're in this fixed frame
which brings up another subtle point
about velocities and pick an inertial
frames if you are at any fixed point in
an inertial frame you don't have to be a
toe you can be right where you are this
term is always the same the velocity of
this moving object relative to the frame
is the same to any observer in the frame
any fixed observer in the frame okay
and finally the you but that you if I
the part of the contribution to the
velocity due to the rotation of this
thing you can see it from out there
right it moves well the road
Asian contribution is this the dog
running around is this and the movement
of the train is the first term okay
alright and this is the general formula
for the derivative of a vector in a
translating rotating frame yeah I'm not
a presented war via the inspector of the
object where these are all vectors and
I've gotten a little careless about
drawing my underlines when I haven't
broken them down into components this is
a vector and we can do this because
we're relying on formulas for the sums
of vectors so it's the vector there's a
vector describing the velocity of the
train for example if it's moving in the
capital I hat direction you have to say
that and this this may actually be the
dog at the moment you catch him you know
the frames like this and let's say he's
running in the Y direction his direction
at that instant in time is in the
lowercase J hat direction relative to
this frame right and that J hat
direction has some angle with respect to
this frame which if you want to reduce
this these velocities down to the unit
vectors in the inertial frame you can do
that but you're going to have to account
for the angles of this reference frame
compared to that one so cosine Thetas
and sine Thetas and that kind of thing
one important point about this general
expression for the derivative of a
vector in a rotating frame which
therefore applies to this case because
this is just a specific example of loss
of derivative of a position vector
giving evil
city this term and this term these
account for the change in length of the
vector so just to keep it real in terms
of velocities you see a velocity this
due to the fact that the valve velocity
vector itself is changing in length or
in this case the R vector is changing in
lakes of the velocity has something to
do with the change in length this term
is due only to the fact that it is
rotating rotating but the dogs not
running is his position vector changing
in length no so this this term here
comes from taking this derivative of the
position vector within the Moro tating
frame so this accounts for the change in
length of that position vector this
accounts for the rotation this term is
the same as seen from in any to any
frame this is a subtlety this term you
get the same answer if you see it from
here
this velocity this contribution the dog
speed with respect to this this frame
it's in is the same to you out there in
the fixed frame as it is to somebody
sitting here in the frame moving with
them important point it'll become more
important as you do problems you need to
remember that that you can doesn't
matter where your calculated you're
given the velocity of the dog in this
frame and little ijk components it is in
magnitude exactly the same velocity as
you would see it in the fixed frame but
then you just have to account for the
right unit vectors and so forth yes
the direction is say in any frame also
it's just that you're going to you have
to decide which unit vectors to
represent it in and when you're in this
frame it's easiest to represent it in
little ijk right but if you're in the
fixed frame you may want to actually
know the velocity in the fixed frames
unit vectors and there's just geometric
conversions it'll give you that yes so
read she says if theta is a function of
time if you were trying to convert this
you know this dogs running in the
y-direction which is going to in the
master frame over there is going to have
a component in the negative capital I
hat and positive capital J hat direction
right and you could break down let's say
his velocity vectors like this you could
break it down into a component that's
parallel to the ground and a component
perpendicular to the ground
and those then would be in that
reference frame so those conversions is
just you you've all I would think have
done some problems using polar
coordinates and the conversion between x
and y and R and theta is you used cosine
Thetas and sine Thetas to compute it
right so read that handout on kinematics
because it explicitly shows you it
proves this formula by doing just that
it puts everything in terms of Thetas
that are functions of time and it's kind
of a long painful process but you can do
that grind it out and you will then when
you assemble the terms you end up with
this and once you know this formula it's
far far easier than to having to have to
calculate all this in terms of Thetas
and Theta dots and sines and cosines
okay all right that's good that's
important stuff we're going to make
great use of these formulas over the
rest of the term so I'm going to just
take a break from kinematics it's time
you'll talk a little bit about Newton's
laws because we really want to be able
to do dynamics problems and so this has
been about describing the motion and now
we want to talk about the laws on which
we we depend in order to be able to
calculate things and to draw right
equations of motion and so forth
so any final questions about kinematics
because they can change topics yes
yeah I think about acceleration now do
you really mean is that what you mean
because they talked much about
acceleration this one so this is this
equation is true of any vector it's this
is basically vector calculus it's true
of any vector in a rotating frame its
time derivative with respect to a fixed
frame is the derivative you would see in
the rotating frame which is just the
change of length of the vector and the
part due to the fact that you are making
it rotate you're going to will will do
examples of this I promise you very soon
so you'll see how it's applied okay okay
so let's let's do a quick review of
Newton
so Newton's laws he had three of them
and we're all pretty familiar with the
second the first though is called the
law of inertia and basically the first
law says if AB object is motionless in
the absence of forces what happens stays
motionless or if it's at some constant
velocity in the absence of forces it
stays it stays at constant velocity
right so I'm going to these have been
stated in many ways over the years I'm
just going to try to come up with short
ones for the board so in the absence of
forces
the absence of forces and a of particle
moves with constant velocity in fact
Newton only talked about motions of
particles not as in little tiny things
not about rigid bodies that have finite
dimensions he thought of the planets
appropriately as particles second law
second law I won't write it all out but
basically F equals MA
they're vectors equals the time
derivative of the linear momentum that's
what we know it's a second law the sum
of all the external forces equals the
mass times the acceleration another
statement of the second law okay so you
know that one that's the one you're most
familiar with third one what's the third
one every action has an equal and
opposite reaction and I'm going to draw
a picture for this one so here's a
particle here's another particle this is
particle to particle one there's a force
on this particle that's the force on two
due to the presence of one you know the
one they've each got a little gravity a
little attraction for one another and
this one has a force on particle 1 due
to particle 2 they could be two planets
and basically what he said is that for
every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction that means that F 2 1
equals minus F 1 2 and this is what this
is called the strong form of Newton's
third law which the forces are equal
opposite and collinear they actually
point exactly
opposite one another and this is true of
mechanical systems you get some rather
interesting subtleties when you get into
electromagnetic fields and charged
particles and things like that so you
have to think really carefully but for
the mechanical systems this strong form
will suit us just fine okay Newton those
are the three laws Newton made one major
condition for those to be true what is
the assumption that must be satisfied
for these laws to be true I hear an
inertial reference frame right and
that's what he assumed you have to be in
an inertial frame for these statements
to be true so then what I want to spend
a few minutes talking about is basically
what's what's an inertial frame because
that's going to be really important in
this subject when you start getting on
things that move and rotate things
sometimes are not inertial it's like
actually quick question so a reference
frame so we had our fixed frame up there
sitting on the ground here on the earth
is the earth and inertial reference
frame standing here observing things
how many I want I won't show our hands I
really want some participation here how
many you think you're nervous an
inertial frame raise your hand it's true
how many think is not true how many
think it depends on what what the
problem is he says it depends on what
you're focusing on so you know really
depends on the sizes of the forces and
the motion you're interested in can you
give me an example in which the earth
cannot be assumed to be a an inertial
frame practical example impractical
rotation of the earth is slowing that's
interesting to account for that you
would definitely not be able to just
assume where inertial but what's a
everyday example of where if you're
trying to solve the problem in this
field you couldn't make this inertial
assumption well they shouldn't know for
the most part you can get most of it but
yeah
okay that's a good that's a good one in
order to account for the circulation you
have to take into account the Earth's
motion let me give you an example
clocks pendulum clocks does the speed of
a clock change is it different at high
noon from midnight what do you think yes
or no I mean the actual speed of a clock
the length of a second would be
different at noon on the earth a
pendulum clock from midnight how many
think that might be true it's different
how many don't believe that it would be
true how many just not raising their
hands come on you guys let's get what
that okay so the effective acceleration
of gravity is that that pendulum feels
is different at noon from midnight and
one reason is because at noon the sun's
pulling toward away from the surface of
the earth and at midnight the Sun's
gravity is pulling toward in the same
direction as toward the center of the
earth the total effective gravitational
pull that the pendulum field changes due
to the rotation of the earth would it
feel the sum of the forces on the
pendulum includes the Earth's gravity
and the Sun's gravity the moon also does
this
so there's daily variations in the
Klaipeda pendulum clocks just because of
the Earth's rotation with respect to the
Sun and the moon yeah
so you she says that even great enough
to be measurable so I have a friend a
guy named Hugh hunt he's a professor
teaches dynamics at Cambridge University
and he takes he is the keeper of the
Trinity College clock Trinity colleges
were Newton was so he took me to his
clock one day up in this tower it's got
about a two meter pendulum on it and he
has got that clock to run so that it
gains no more than one second per month
he's really tuned it up carefully and
the key to being able to do that is to
not is to do is to do things overrun
monthly averages so he's got a tune so
on the over a month it does it just
barely gains a tiny bit but if you
measure it very carefully over the
course of the day it has amazingly
significant at large fluctuations one of
them is due to the thing I just
described so if you're really trying to
keep close time it matters okay another
one is gunnery you're shooting long
range you're trying to hit a target the
fact that the Earth rotates you will not
hit the target if you don't account for
the effects that are caused by the
Earth's rotation and it's one of the
first reasons that people got into
understanding the importance of whether
or not it's an inertial frame was
gunnery in the old days from naval ships
and so forth okay so we have three laws
I want to talk a little bit about the
first and the third we're going to use
the second a lot so the first law most
people think of the first law as being a
special case of the second right
it's just when there's no forces nothing
changes but I think the first law is
useful in its own right and one of the
reasons why it's called the law of
inertia it's the law that allows you to
do a test to discover whether or not
you're actually in an inertial frame
useful to be able to do that so I'm
going to give you a going to give you an
example and actually I did want to ask
you a question so three with three
possible answers to this question an
inertial frame can and how to have posed
this if you're in an inertial for
name can it be accelerating if you're an
inertial frame can it be rotating and if
you're or if you're an inertial frame it
can neither accelerate or rotate so
which of those three answers is the best
answer for conditions to be in an
inertial frame non accelerating non
rotating or both how many believe nan
wrote non accelerating just not
accelerate how many believe in just not
rotating how many believe both both is
right if you are in a frame which is
rotating or accelerating it's not
inertial okay so just rotation causes a
not to be accelerating so let's test
that what a pick pick two cases quickly
- let's use this law of inertia to have
a to set up eight a test to see if a
couple different frames are in fact
inertial so I've got a cart here and I'm
sitting here or you are we're sitting on
the card and this cart is accelerating
in acceleration of a with respect to O
is I'll call it a naught I have this
carts accelerating in that way that that
direction the positive I hat direction
okay now I'm sitting here on the cart
not very sensitive and I want to test
whether or not I'm in an inertial frame
so I've got let's pretend this card I've
got an air table there frictionless
table I've got a hockey puck and I set
it down in the frictionless table and
let it go what happens what do I observe
so the puck will accelerate you're
saying towards me right didn't move so
she says the puck will move towards you
if you let it go so is that an
indication that your of whether or not
you're in an inertial frame so the test
this is first law house so the test if
you're in this industry manned you want
to know whether or not this is a
commercial frame and I claim you can set
this puck out there if you're in an
inertial frame what should it do if it
moves there's something going on
something fishy right okay so the
acceleration and we'll call the Puckett
B so the acceleration of B with respect
to O and there's no rotation here so the
acceleration of B with respect to O it
can be written as the acceleration of a
with respect to O plus the acceleration
of B with respect to a and what can if
now this is a this is O here this is an
inertial frame and if in if it's an
inertial frame and there are no forces
in the X Direction acting on this puck
that I'm going to say that the sum of
the forces on that puck equal zero and
therefore what can I say about the
expected the acceleration of the puck
what's the acceleration of the puck has
seen from oh it's got to be zero no
forces so the summation of the forces
with respect to this o frame in the
x-direction if there's zero that implies
the acceleration of B with respect to O
has got to be zero okay knowing that I
can now solve for the acceleration of B
with respect to a and that's going to be
minus
the acceleration of a with respect to O
that's minus a naught I have so you are
correct in saying that it moves but it
actually accelerates from your point of
view what you see sitting there in a you
were going to see this accelerate in the
opposite direction
and that's a dead giveaway that you're
not in an inertial frame okay come on
okay
so a little harder problem
now we've got a merry-go-round okay and
it's fixed not in the Train it just
sitting here but if you can spin and
you're sitting at a so you're up above
this merry-go-round looking down on it
and it's rotating you're out there
you're in an inertial frame but now you
come over to here and you sit right here
at the center and if you're right at the
center you might not actually feel a
thing right and there's no windows so
you this is could be a spaceship out
there if slowly rolling over so you're
sitting inside of this system no windows
right at the center can't feel a thing
and I want you to construct a test be
using the first law that'll tell you
whether or not you're in an inertial
frame what might you do
all right set a ball on the ground and
see if it rolls out to the edge right
and see if it moves just is this eye
going into the epic gravity or zarua uh
let's let's let's really make it a
merry-go-round but you can't so there's
gravity so I just don't I want gravity
to be useful here it keeps the thing on
the surface doesn't just go drifting off
so yeah it's let's say we have gravity
the axis is vertical you're sitting here
but you can't see outside and you want
to do this test so do you agree if you
set the ball down you might learn
something okay so if you say you set the
ball down you're here watching and
here's the ball and let's say it's a you
got a ball and you actually have a
string on the ball you set it out there
so initially you've got this ball out
there and you're sitting here at the
center and your sister this
merry-go-round is going round and round
what should you what should what can you
sense that tells you that you're not in
an inertial frame if you're holding on
to this string does the ball move first
of all would the ball move if I'm
sitting you're hanging onto the string
and I set it out there and set it down
no one move but what do you feel in the
string tension in the string okay so you
know you've got indication number one
that there's something fishy
okay now you let go of the string what
should happen so you said it ought to go
out alright but what now I'm going to
ask you a little harder question what
direction should the ball travel in once
you release it
radially outwards I have one one shot at
radially outwards any other thoughts so
I had one one postulate that it will
occur it will go away and curve off
right which way would it curve stood so
it doesn't you're saying not radially
you say it's going to curve opposite of
the spin he says it will curve opposite
to the spin this is from the point of
view on on the on the merry-go-round
point of view off the merry-go-round
might be easier to reason this so now
you're up above the America round in it
inertial frame you know up above this
America around just looking down like
sitting up in a tree looking down on it
what do you see
all right this is an argument for you'll
see if you're on their merry go around
you'll see radial motion motion if you
in the tree you'll see the curve so
we're going to do yeah okay all right I
think we better take a vote here so the
possible answers are from how do we
frame this from the an inertial frame
looking down on it answer a is it will
go in a curved path answer B is it will
go in a straight radial line answer C as
it does any other guesses no other
guesses so it's the only two choices it
curves or it goes in a straight radial
line so how many vote for everybody has
to participate how many vote for Street
goes is straight radial line let's have
it straight out radial line from the
point of view of the fixed reference
frame okay you could do a number of okay
how many from the point of view of this
fixed frame looking down on it we'll see
it curve how many vote for that and how
many didn't vote those are don't knows
huh don't all right so a and B are wrong
a and B are dead wrong and you could you
could have figured out what the answer
is if you went right back to basics back
to Newton's laws when the string is
released the sum of the forces on object
are what in the in the direction that it
can travel still got gravity pushing on
it but that's it can't go in that
direction so what if you did a free body
diagram what are the forces in the in
that horizontal direct plane that it's
sitting on
I'm here's in Tripucka forest I hear
friction let's make the table
frictionless so it can easy to move no
friction
I hear centrifugal force zero radial
direction so you are the one to provide
it that force you're on the
merry-go-round you set it out there and
held the string you set it out there and
some radius R and so because when you
set it down you're already turning so
you just set it down with respect to the
remarried around it's not moving you
just set it down okay if what are the
forces what to just draw the Freebody
diagram here's here's this puck and
you've released the string and you got
mg downwards and you have a normal force
upwards and you have no friction so what
and I hear centrifugal force but well
that's been that was a guess somebody
said straight out and the answer is no
and we're going to figure it out
first of all we got to sort out the
forces what are the forces on this thing
so I heard scientifical force
that's not caused by what sort of like
the boxer that you got was from the Hat
but that starts out where you set it
down and once you shut it down it's
there and then your initial velocity
from setting it out there yes the change
in direction before so we change the
direction of of the ball once the strain
cuts the direction of no longer changes
and ball jokes direction that is
tangential to the circle all right
the man has it right you probably
couldn't hear him he says when you let
it go it goes tangential to the circle
and that's true the forces on in this
direction in the horizontal direction
once you release the object there are no
forces centrifugal force is a
construction of convenience called a
fictitious force and we'll talk about
that later it is not a real force it as
a result of an acceleration and as the
result of the acceleration when you are
making it go in a circle there is indeed
that tension is what some people call
the centrifugal force holding it there
but once you release it that's no longer
there and if there are no external
forces acting on the object in the
horizontal direction what's the mass
times acceleration
therefore what's the acceleration zero
and it's LA what's its velocity at that
moment in time okay
all right so you have an R Omega
velocity it's tangential to the motion
so let's make this my little X and this
my react C's attached to the
merry-go-round this thing is moving in
the J hat direction at R B with respect
to a in the J hat direction that is the
velocity of B with respect to a at the
moment you release it okay so it had
better run off tangential to the circle
at the moment of release so let's test
it now I want you to I want you to be my
quality control person if I smack
somebody with this something going to
hurt them
squeeze it soft and harmless all right
okay
so when should I release it if I want to
you know hit the MIT sweatshirt sitting
up there when it's out here right I'll
see if I can do it
all right so we've proved the and I
better not try it again I probably can't
do it twice in a row okay it was in a
straight line
radial straight line was one guess this
is got it
so this tangential straight line is the
right answer
I can't quite hear you and I thought the
Omega didn't I
sorry about that so it is Omega the
result of Omega cross R b/a so 2 Omega
with respect to O RBA in the J direction
yeah-ah sub actually I was out you
almost I almost forgot this she is
talking about what is the person see on
the merry-go-round what do you actually
see on the merry-go-round certainly
doesn't go radio we've proven that right
but the person on the merry-go-round is
you're turning and this thing is going
off in a straight line with respect to
the fixed frame and you're turning away
from it so looking down on it I release
it here it goes off in that direction
your point of observation you see it
here but now a short time later when you
when you've rotated to this point and
you just you just keep in your you're
just keeping your eye on it you see this
thing start to move but this this is the
spot that it was sitting on which is now
moved to here but its position is now
there you see it moving away from you
and as you get up to say here then it
will have moved out a radius this far
actually that's not you don't know how
fast your well you're actually going
exactly the same speed it is so you
should have you've gone the arc length
here it's gone a quarter of a circle out
to about there same point right here but
now you see it as being going off like
that to you it's hooking off in a
direction opposite to the direction of
rotation so the young man up there who
described that early on was that
complete exactly right so from your
point of view go home
that and then if you go all the way
around it'll appear to come back it'll
be further away but it'll get it'll come
you'll be back down to the point where
you see it released so it'll look like
it goes from your point of view okay
good one okay we've got a few minutes
left I want to do something really
important with the third law so the
first law is actually pretty important
and very handy the second law we're
going to make a lots of use of so I'm
talking minute about the third law the
third law is responsible for a law that
we use they're an application that we
use all the time and let's see how this
works out so Newton's third law is the
one that says F 2 1 is equal to F 1 2 so
we have these two particles and I called
them 2 and 1 and I'll give this one mass
1 mass 2 and I'm going to say second law
tells me that the sum of the forces
vectors external forces on two is in
this one let's say it's got it has
things active forces acting on it Fi and
it has this little F 2 1 so the forces
here are the the external forces they're
vectors plus F some of the forces on to
so force is on to do to one that's that
external influence of the other particle
okay and this had better be equal to
- em - eh - I'll call it and I'll be
with respect to some fixed some inertial
frame so the sum of all these external
forces on that particle to have better
be equal to the mass times the
acceleration of particle - and the same
thing can be said about particle one so
I've really confused things here there's
two and there's one boy okay guys help
keep me honest here so now that we say
that some of the forces on one is equal
to these external applied forces plus f1
- the force caused by the other body all
right and those had better equal to m1
a1 zero okay and these are also equal to
the time derivative of M two V two is
zero that's the momentum time derivative
of the momentum it's fixed mass so it's
just the derivative velocity gives the
acceleration so these are clearly the
same formula and this is the time
derivative of M 1 V 1 with respect to O
DT and we call that P 2 dot P 1 dot so
these are statements that are applying
second law to each of these particles so
if I want to compute the total momentum
of the system linear momentum the total
momentum of the system it's going to be
P 1 plus P 2 they're vectors and I want
to take the time derivative of that
total momentum
just the time derivative of a sum is the
sum of the time derivatives and so I get
a p1 dot plus a p2 dot okay but I know
what those are I have expressions for
them so this is f1 external forces plus
f1 2 plus the f2 external forces plus f2
1 these two things this one plus this
one basically is the sum of the two time
derivatives of the momentum but what's
the sum of this term in that term zero
and that then allows you to say that
this is the sum of the external forces
on a system is equal to the time rate of
change of the linear momentum of the
system okay that's this basically this
statement and it has nothing to do with
internal forces and this allows you to
say that the time rate of change of the
linear momentum of a rigid body for
example so rigid body is made up of a
whole mess of different particles you
can separate this into a whole bunch of
little chunks and treat each one of them
as a particle which has connection has
forces with particles next to it and all
those internal forces so these are the
internal forces all of those internal
forces are equal and opposite and cancel
so it's really the third law that allows
you to say if you have a system of
particles
that this that the time rate of change
of the total momentum of the system is
zero if there's no external forces
acting on it that's where you get the
conservation of momentum the law of
conservation of momentum okay that's
that's a consequence of third law okay
so either you have a homework problem
that has just about this you have a
bunch of particles m1 mir-1 with respect
to o r i with respect to o okay and you
have all these particles out there and i
want to find the center of mass of this
group of particles so the center of mass
is a vector and it's a say it's here so
I'm looking for our G with respect to O
so it's a quantity that I define our G
with respect to O times the summation of
the MIS so I am postulating there's some
there's a place out there that if I
multiply it by the sum of the MIS I get
the same answer as if I summed the M I
are i OS okay and that's I'm going to
define the center of mass as our G with
respect to O is a summation of each
particle times its position vector
divided by the sum of the masses which
is just the total mass of the system
okay that's a definition of center of
mass this is a vector and these are
vectors okay so that's all there is the
center of mass and I'll do a quick
if I take a time derivative of rgo then
it's equal to the summation of the mi
times the are iOS but their time
derivatives then I can put a dot right
there so I have to write out D by DT
over Mt but that's just the summation of
the individual momenta of each of the
particles over Mt very handy little
formula and if I take another time
derivative so I get an R geo double dot
then it's just the summation of the time
derivatives of the individual moment
again over this so this is a statement I
move this to the other side MT rgo
double dot equals the summation of the
time derivatives of the individual
momenta and that's the total momentum of
the system times its time derivative so
just from third law you can basically
can come up with all of the momentum
linear momentum formulas this is a
statement for a rigid body the mass
times the acceleration of the center of
mass a total mass of a rigid body times
the acceleration of the center of mass
is equal to the time rate of change of
the total momentum of that object very
important formula you've used a lot
right so I'll take quick story and then
we'll knock off so the couple to three
years ago we have dr. hill exams in
mechanical engineering and we in the
dynamics oral exam we had eight students
a few years ago and they were asked to
find the center of mass of an object it
was just a step in a harder problem and
seven out of the eight students could
not remember the definition of the
center of mass now they could do a
grande equations and nasty dynamics
problems but it kind of forgotten some
of these really really basic things so I
have one demo to show you just about
just a illustrate center of mass so
center of mass we know how to calculate
it this is a rod how can I simply find
the center of mass of this thing balance
it okay young lady here says move my
fingers where do you think the center of
mass is right in the middle okay let's
find it should this work by the way you
ever done this alright the center of
mass I have to be able to just about
balance this thing there so center mass
is in the middle that's because I
cheated I put a piece of steel on this
end okay all right but indeed you know
you might figure out why is it that I
can actually do this and make it work do
with a broom stick you can do with any
object the key is it'll work as long as
the friction coefficients are the same
on both fingers which it's really easy
to find center of mass that way so this
got a little steel weight in the end
okay we're done for today and keep doing
see you on Thursday